What was the catalyst for starting this program?
So, first off, I'll just say
my mother is probably one of my biggest inspirations.
I grew up sort of watching her navigate entrepreneurship
at a very young age.
She migrated here from Columbia,
basically, you know, right when she had me,
and she's an esthetician,
and she opened up a medi spa
literally by doing one chair in another salon at a time
and then grew it to three salons at one point.
Wow.
And then kind of the impetus of it all
is one day, with my husband, we were trying to get massages
and I didn't love our options.
We didn't love our options.
It felt like we were gonna have to splurge
or we were gonna have to pay next to nothing,
and I felt really guilty for very different reasons,
and I hated that.
I felt like there was something missing right there
in the middle.
And then I guess it all just sort of snowballed.
I was like, "Wow, I think I need to kind of, you know,
change up what the spa industry looks like
and modernize it and make it more attainable, accessible
and also inspiring."
Where did the advocating
for mental health support come in?
So really it kind of started with my husband.
So growing up, the word mental health wasn't thrown around.
I'm an older millennial and I'm Latina,
so the way we deal with mental health
is either yelling it out or not speaking about it at all,
and I feel like I didn't have a healthy outlet
growing up and I didn't even talk about it.
I didn't know it was a thing.
And it wasn't until my husband really came forward
with what he goes through every day.
He has an anxiety disorder
and it was really eye opening.
And I had to completely immerse myself
in what that may feel like, and I still do.
And so for Chillhouse, I knew that, you know,
even though we do services in our spa
and our products are catered around
bringing that spa experience home,
I didn't want it to just end at that.
I wanted to be able to speak to people that, you know,
we fully understand that not every anxiety,
depression, stress can be cured with pretty nail art
and massages, though I wish that were the case.
You really have to do the work,
so our goal is really to be able to partner
with organizations that are doing that heavy work
and support them however we can,
and really wanna continue to de-stigmatize
what mental health is
and make it more of a conversation point,
not just have it be something
that we continue to bottle in every day.
Because there is such a tie
between wellness and beauty and the mental game,
and I love that your husband inspired this
and that you are able to fold it in and incorporate it.
And I think that it's just wonderful-
Thank you.
That you're taking care
of people on so many different levels,
but trying to, like,
Venn diagram it
(audience applauds)
in the same way with mental wellness.
Absolutely.
Now, we're gonna do something today
that's a flower art.
I happen to love the word flower,
all things flower, FLOWER Beauty, Flower Films.
I live under the banner of flower,
so I was excited about this.
Will you teach me how to do this?
Yeah. So it's really simple.
I see you have a red nail bed right there,
so I think a white would be a great
kind of contrast to the red.
So you wanna use the little marble coaster there
to dip as much polish as you-
Oh, oh, I see where you're going with that.
So throw it on there and that's kinda gonna be
like your home base for dipping.
Oh, this is fun.
And dotting.
Dipping and dotting.
Okay.
So, just kind of, you know, light little dot right here,
or like put the little dotting tool.
Am I doing a pedal or the center?
So you're gonna go around.
So you're gonna basically do a bunch of dots,
five to be exact, around,
you're trying to connect the dots
and you don't wanna press super hard
because that could maybe potentially
smudge the polish underneath, so keep it
really light, so-
Okay, you demo
and I'll follow.
Two,
three,
four, and five, and you see?
It just kind of
leaves a little,
(audience applauds)
thank you, thank you.
Words of encouragement.
So, super cute and you leave a little bit of space
right in the center there
so that you get that little center
of flower contrast.
(audience laughs)
You've got it.
You've got it, just connect the dots, five total.
Oh.
And so this
is such a cute design that you can do with your daughters.
I am loving this.
My second and third one are not so bad.
It just took me-
Oh my God, you killed it.
It's so cute.
(audience applauds)
My first one is like the pancake and-
Always, that's a great analogy.
My first pancake was a disaster.
Okay, we heard from some of the women
that you've helped thanks to your generosity
and if it's okay, can I share it with you?
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait.
Take a look.
Cyndi, thank you for recognizing #HalfTheStory
and for advocating for mental health.
Cyndi's support of #HalfTheStory
has allowed us to grow and help even more youth.
Thanks to Cyndi's support of #HalfTheStory,
we've been able to expand our reach
to youth all over the globe to join our mission
in de-stigmatizing digital wellness.
Cyndi's support of Sad Girls Club
helps us expand our programming.
We've been able to offer more sessions
and touch more people all around the world.
I know that your support means the world
to not just me, but everyone that's a part
of the Sad Girls Club community.
Thank you to Cyndi for recognizing #HalfTheStory
and advocating for mental health.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, that was really special.
And that's not all.
Our team at FLOWER Beauty was so inspired by you
that they wanna make a $2,500 donation-
Oh my God.
To the Sad Girls Club
(audience cheers)
and because I am-
Oh my God. I'm so happy.
As well as I am half of FLOWER Beauty,
so I wanna match that and donate
another 2,500-
Oh my God.
So that we can have that for #HalfTheStory.
So that's a total of $5,000 just to say thank you,
use it to the way you see fit
and keep doing what you're doing.
Thank you so, so, so much.
This means so much.
I always feel like I'm not doing enough for them
and this means the world.
This is exactly why we partnered with them,
so thank you.
I really appreciate it.
So thank you so much.
(upbeat music)